c'est un animal qui divise dans les
pyrénées l'ours brun en 2019 l'office de
la forêt de la biodiversité en compter
au moins 52 dans le massif à protéger
selon les uns à chasser pour d'autres un
débat vieux comme la montagne
l'ours ennemi numéro 1 des bergers
depuis toujours des battues sont
organisées comme le raconte ce chasseur
en 1969
moi je me charge
j'y ai joué par nos trois gémeaux pour
le fuji le nombre d'ours est presque
divisé par deux entre 1954 et 1970 en
1972 la chasse est interdite mais des
ours sont quand même abattu en 1995 il
n'en reste plus que cinq
se pose alors la question de la
réintroduction des 1988
ce qui fait débat chez des élus et les
bergers dire en cinq courses
ça veut dire on pose aussi le problème
d'installation des jeunes bergers on
pose le problème de la continuité du
pastoralisme la réintroduction est
lancée en 1996
jiva et melba deux femelles de slovénie
de la même espèce comme ours pyrénéens
huit ans plus tard en 2004 neuf
individus sont répertoriés et pourtant
canal mortes s'envolent tout espoir de
conserver une ligne et d'ours de pure
souche pyrénéenne
c'était la dernière femelle existantes
l'ourse cannelle tuée par un chasseur
pro et anti ours c# à nouveau sur la
politique à adopter et en 2010 c'est une
victoire pour les opposants pas de
réintroductions massives simplement des
remplacements quand les ours sont morts
accidentellement et on compte sur le
croit naturel comme c'était attendu les
ours se reproduise
ils sont estimés à 43 en 2010 est au
dessus du niveau de 1970 un espoir de
cohabitation entre l'animal et l'homme
le nombre de dégâts par course est très
inférieure à ce qu'il a pu être par le
passé et c'est bien la preuve qu'on ne
peut faire cohabiter un pastoralisme
vivant et moderne et la présence d'une
espèce comme l'ours dans les pyrénées
pour autant la paix n'est pas
d'actualité en octobre 2018 deux ours
portant des bébés sont lâchés dans les
pyrénées malgré l'opposition d'élus
locaux et les menaces de certains
éleveurs on se défendra
on ira on ira là chasseurs en 2019 738
attaques d'ours ont été comptabilisés
dans les pyrénées au total ils ont tué
1173 animaux
[Musique]